my name is Audra Dunning and I'm a
senior political economy major here at
the college and I have the pleasure of
introducing to you dr. Charles T Reuben
Charles T Reuben is the Murray Clement
Roudier endowed chair professor at
Tulane University he earned his Bachelor
of Arts in philosophy and political
science at Case Western Reserve and a
PhD in political science at Boston
College a recipient of the Madison
visiting fellowship in the James Madison
program for American ideals in
institutions at Princeton University dr.
Reuben is a contributing editor at the
New Atlantis his current research and
publications focus on emerging
technologies such as nanotechnology and
artificial intelligence and the idea
that they will allow for the redesign of
humanity he is editor of conservation
reconsidered nature virtue and American
liberal democracy and he is author of
the green crusade rethinking the roots
of environmentalism and Eclipse of man
human extinction and the meaning of
progress please join me in welcoming dr.
Charles Rubin
[Applause]
thank you I'm the after-dinner
entertainment right it's wonderful to
know it's wonderful to be here at
Hillsdale I've I've known of this place
for years and years and years and even
as I began to know people who came here
like my good friend will Morrissey it
still had had the aura of a kind of
shangri-la or Brigadoon or but but now
I'm here right and so that's it's it's
it's wonderful it's one of the great
truisms of our time that our ethics need
to catch up with our technology or that
we stand in need of some new
technological ethics the challenge may
be posed in this very general form or it
may be related to some particular
technological innovation as was the
suppose as with the supposed need for
some new ethic to cover the
life-and-death choices made by computer
piloted cars or with respect to privacy
issues or in relation to genetic
engineering or brain machine interfaces
the underlying idea seems to be pretty
much the same in all cases technology
has given us some unprecedented power
over nature and over each other which in
turn grants us new powers of action and
consequent novel choices that will
require an equally novel ethical outlook
the observation that these unprecedented
powers may in one way or another
threaten the very existence of human
beings as such or of life on earth more
generally is not infrequently adduced to
add urgency to this call for ethical
innovation certainly the premises of
this argument are very hard to deny they
are in some respects the most obvious
thing about the world we encounter day
to day were our culture less
deep in the love of novelty than it is
it might be easier to elevate the call
for a new technological ethic from
truism to simply truth but as it stands
I think there is some prima facie reason
for being suspicious of ideas that fit
so well within our intellectual
inclinations or prejudices after all it
is very flattering to modernity
tightly-bound as it is to the Baconian
project of the conquest of nature for
the relief of man's estate to grant that
it has been so successful at altering
the conditions of human life as to
require a reconsideration of fundamental
ethical categories less abstractly the
call for a new technological ethic is a
kind of pensioners praise of our
flesh-and-blood technological elite the
Masters of disruption who to their great
delight and profit aim to make all that
is solid melts into thin air now in
principle another of the great
characteristics of the modern world
enlightenment might exempt us from such
worries that our vision of what
technology is and does is subject to all
of the strictures of Socrates as
allegory of the cave you know it could
still be true that most of us most of
the time at least with respect to the
things most familiar to us are content
with a world of opinions whose
relationship to the truth is as we might
say casual fortunately for us our
dilemma our any effort to resolve a
dilemma about whether we do or do not
need a new technological ethic to deal
with the novel circumstances technology
seems to create for us is vastly
assisted by the work of 20th century
philosopher Hans Jonas long before it
was fashionable
yonis articulated an argument for a new
technological ethic not so different
from what I have just outlined but very
carefully and very insightful II thought
through
by his own account Jonas's extended
meditations on this topic began in the
late 1950s and culminated in a book that
in English came to be known by the title
the imperative of responsibility in
search for an ethics for the
technological age this is a 1984
translation of works that had been
published in German in 79 and in 81 the
book is said to have inspired European
green parties and also to have
contributed to the thinking behind what
becomes known as the precautionary
principle I'm not sure either of these
relationships represent the most
accurate reflection of Eunice's own
thinking or intention but of course
influential authors don't get to choose
always the nature of their influence I'm
not going to enter tonight into a
discussion of this book with anything
close to the depth and breadth that it
deserves but I will try to lay the
premises upon which Jonas based his
argument for a new technological ethic
before you and suggest why I think that
one could actually accept his premises
more or less at face value and still
believe that the challenged technology
poses for us is better met by a return
to an older understanding of ethics than
progress to a new one Jonas's view of
the dangers posed by the altered
conditions of human choice and action
created by modern technology means as he
understood full well that we will
increasingly need to restrain and
constrain our own choices if we wish to
protect the integrity of human life and
the larger natural world but that
undertaking it seems to me forces us to
take seriously not some new ethic but
the ancient task of ethics habituating
our reason and emotions to work together
to control our infinite desires here let
me note
my debt to CS Lewis for this concise and
to my mind generally applicable account
of what I'll be calling the old ethics
alrightso Jonas's argument for a new
technological ethic is founded on
showing how the old ethic is based on
assumptions that are simply no longer
true first that the human condition and
human nature are fixed once and for all
second that the basis of knowing what
human nature is that on on the basis of
knowing what human nature is the human
good is readily determinable those who
hurt his words not sure Socrates would
agree but they're his words third that
the realm of human responsibility is
relatively tightly constrained by an
abiding naturally given that transcends
human capacities now note that yonis is
not speaking here about the content of
any particular old ethic he's talking
about the underlying circumstances which
he believes called forth the ethics of
the ancient and indeed the early modern
world and perhaps even all the way up to
Kant now to elaborate on the difference
between the old situation and the
present situation with respect to the
impact of technology he derives four
additional points from the famous
second chorus of Sophocles --is play and
Teagan ii right this is the many things
caused terror and wonder yet nothing is
more terrifying and wonderful than man
or is it can I read it to you many
things cause terror and wonder yet
nothing is more terrifying and wonderful
than man this thing goes across the
Gracey on the blasts of winter storms
passing beneath waters towering round
him the earth eldest of the Gods on
withering and untiring this thing wears
down as his ploughs go back and forth
year after year furring her
with the issue of horses this thing in
snares and carries off the tribe of
like-minded birds the companies of wild
beasts and the Seas marine life with
coils of woven meshes this keenly
skilled man he has power through his
ways over the beasts who traverses the
mountains and haunts the open sky the
shaggy mane horse he tames with yolk and
the untiring of mountain bull both
language and thought swift as wind and
impulses that govern cities he has
taught himself as well as how to escape
the shafts of rain while encamped
beneath open skies all resourceful he
approaches no future thing to come
without resource from Hades alone he
will not contrive to escape refuge from
baffling diseases he has devised
possessing a means of invention a
skillfulness beyond expectation now
toward evil he moves now toward good by
integrating the laws of the earth and
justice under oath sworn to the gods
he is lofty of city city 'less he is the
man with whom aghhhhhh nobility because
of his daring dwells may he never reside
at my hearth or think like me whoever
does such things from this account of
the human condition which by the way is
by no means simply confirmed by the
other choruses of Antigone
yonis concludes first very unsurprising
observation that Tecna is equally
capable of being put to good or bad uses
second that ethics are essentially about
human to human relationships and third
that what it means to be human is fixed
finally in your nieces reading the
chorus teaches that the realm of s that
ethics is focused on the local and the
short-term the world of the city meaning
that it has relatively modest cognitive
particularly what with respect to
matters where prediction might come into
play here again I want to stress Joan
Jonas is not so much talking about the
content of any particular pre-modern
ethic he's trying to understand the
circumstances that those ethics were
responding to in order to develop then
the contrast with our current situation
our circumstances are such that human
nature and the human condition are no
longer fixed arguably already technology
has altered the human condition in
serious ways by for example significant
life extension and the alleviation in so
many parts of the world of the tightest
constraints of natural scarcity but more
and more we can and do imagine and
aspire to using technology to more
radical alterations of our own
biologically given secondly the
productive infrastructure that makes
these alterations possible has had an
impact on the workings of natural
ecosystems has it in fact many would say
worn away the oldest of God's we might
debate how much that impact has been
whether they are better or worse but
they've happened certainly we have grown
accustomed to thinking that the fate of
the earth has somehow become our
responsibility under these circumstances
choices that follow from the ethical
neutrality of Technology become
considerably more consequential we are
way beyond the knife that can be used to
save a life in surgery or take a life in
passion our technological choices have
the potential for radical changes to the
naturally given changes that we would be
global and multi-generational
scope the consequences would therefore
extend far beyond what we see in front
of us in space and time so the ability
to know whether or not we are doing the
right thing becomes a matter at best
involving complicated judgments by
specialists and at worst a matter that
exceeds present human capacities to
predict the future
hence we tell ourselves nature as such
which in any case we have largely shorn
of moral significance by the turn to
modern scientific materialism can no
longer serve as that ready guide too
cute the human good and of course as far
as any guide to the human good we are
skeptics culturally speaking about the
extent to which any such guidance is
even possible it is fashionable to
eschew universalistic master narratives
and favor instead the free play of moral
individualism putting these points
together I think we can say yonis
believes that technology has widened and
deepened the scope of our actions beyond
what old ethics imagined in doing so it
has increased both factual and moral
uncertainty with respect to the
consequences of our actions the
existence of a natural order that
transcended human capacity meant that
the bad consequences of ethical failings
or misjudgments would be localized
however terrible they might be within
that local context in contrast for us
lacking any normative conceptions drawn
from nature we find ourselves living on
a kind of light knife's edge of global
disaster so Jonas's account of things a
little later in the book Jonas will
endorse what he calls a heuristics of
fear that is to say he encourages
thinking about the future in light of
the worst-case and it is more than
likely that already in this first
chapter he's engaged in that enter
prai's it's possible then that his dire
view of the future possibilities should
be moderated moderated first by
reminding ourselves of the benefits we
regularly accrue from our technological
prowess like the fact that we're all
here tonight how can human beings in
advanced technological societies not be
grateful for lives that are so much less
poor nasty brutish and short than the
historical norm solitary being the one
outlier here our ingenuity regularly
allows us to address problems of
material existence that at no great
distance of generations would have been
regarded as without solution and despite
decades if not centuries of warnings
about passing points of no return we
continue to make this variety of moral
material progress excuse me there art
seems to me three things wrong with this
admittedly very powerful response to
Jonases more dire conclusions the first
is that it doesn't deal with the classic
joke right the man who jumps off a high
building and somebody says is he's
passing the 42nd floor how's it going
fine he calls back we don't know the
second is that although it seems to have
a quarrel with the onus it is in fact
just another route to reaching Eunice's
own conclusion about the need for a new
technological ethic for indeed we do
live in a world of Perpetual material
progress and ever-increasing comfort
that fact alone might be enough to force
us to rethink any ethics that are not
correspondingly dynamic and that are
predicated on limits beyond our power to
control but a third point in support of
Jonas's rather dire picture is for me
anyway the most dispositive he was
writing certainly very much under the
influence of the environmentalist views
of the 50s 60s and
70s that we faced more or less immediate
prospects of ecological disaster but
it's not clear to me that that kind of
problem really was his core concern he
saw from early on the world we now live
in where the threat of human extinction
from our stupidity or cupidity in
treatment of natural ecosystems is at
least matched and I think exceeded by
the threat that comes from the use of
technology for deliberate projects of
human extinction projects undertaken in
the name of a charitable effort to
correct all the manifests defects of our
naturally given being foremost among
which of course is our mortality call it
what you will it goes under many names
transhumanism post humanism
singularitarianism Extro pian ism h+ the
desirability of replacing fragile
biological humans with some
instantiation of intelligence initially
at least in some sense of our own design
but in any case an instantiation that is
more capable and more robust than we are
may not be the most broadly held opinion
in our society but it is increasingly an
opinion held by those in the technology
sector who are taking some of the most
consequential steps towards that future
whether they intend it or not despite
the fact that it is acknowledged to be
formally incomprehensible to merely
human intelligence as such as our own
this posthuman vision of the future
increasingly also excites the
imaginations of some of our most
creative thinkers and thinking of
science fiction authors who are
constantly straining to write
comprehensible novels about a future
that is supposed to be incomprehensible
to mere human beings it's a challenge
for these reasons I'm going to accept
tonight Jonas's conclusion that modern
technology changed it challenges us with
novel circumstances but does that mean
we need a novel ethic to respond to the
challenge about this second claim I'm
skeptical Yodas himself believes he's
identified a novel ethical principle
more precisely an ethical imperative
that will be the basis for the restraint
we must exercise to make sure that human
life persists into the future quoting
now act so that the effects of your
action are compatible with the
permanence of genuine human life or
expressed negatively Act so that the
effects of your action are not
destructive of the future possibility of
such life or simply do not compromise
the conditions of an indefinite
continuation of humanity on earth you'll
hear all of you some of you the sort of
baleful influence of Conte Ron yonus but
that's what he thinks this is the
substance of the of the new ethic this
imperative is novel because only in our
own time has it become necessary only in
our own time has human power becomes
sufficiently consequential to require we
bring the existence of humanity into the
indiv into the indefinite future under
the umbrella of our ethical concern it
is evident that this imperative would
put us on a path of thinking that could
ground the rejection or use of certain
technologies or their development
although as Jonas understands it
requires a predictive ability to know
whether we would need to do so that in
any given case may be anywhere from
controversial to non-existent although
that too is an aspect of its novelty but
here's the thing the mere articulation
of the imperative neither requires that
we use it or act on it it would have to
be appropriately institutionalized or
operationalized to become an actual
an actual source of restraint of course
all ethical theories face the same
challenge but I think it takes on
altered significance in the context of
yonas analysis I'm gonna see if I can
explain by use of a specific example I
don't think it does great violence to
Eunice's position to reframe it in terms
of a more common rubric the concern for
future generations indeed another of
Eunice's own formulations is do not
compromise the conditions of the
indefinite continuation of humanity on
earth now we are often told that concern
for future generations is deficient
today that we live too much for the
present too much for ourselves we are
not exercising due foresight there you
know I think there's something to that
criticism you know living for the moment
is one of the characteristics of our
particular time it is certainly possible
to find times and places where there was
a much greater concern for future
generations than we routinely express it
is commonly expressed it seems to me as
part of an aristocratic ethos after all
the present holder of land or a title is
just a steward for what previous
generations have bequeathed him sorry it
is usually a him and what he will as
just one link in that gray chain leave
behind him and of course to some degree
that view is expressed at the other end
of the social spectrum as well right
where the you know the peasant classes
believe themselves perpetually bound
under those circumstances they look
forward and backward and they see
exactly the same thing too now however
natural this outlook may appear to a
given aristocrat living in a time of its
full flowering in fact it requires
tremendous discipline and cultivation to
maintain it how do we know that well you
can see
that's true when these aristocratic
worlds start to enter a period of
decline you know read trollope read
Edith Wharton and you see as these
aristocracy's are crumbling around the
edges you get a very good sense of all
the things that used to happen that are
no longer happening habituating reason
and emotions to control desires to
support the aristocratic ethos requires
authoritative legal supports specific
forms of education intensive social
pressures ruthlessly supporting specific
manners and mores not to speak of a
multitude of material conditions right
what's a good aristocratic house without
the grand staircase with all the
ancestor portraits in it right or the
long hallway absent this supporting
framework remnants of an aristocratic
ethos are likely to appear comical or
vicious or ridiculous as is nicely
suggested by some of the episodes of
Matthew Winer's new show the Romanovs
anybody seen that not so much that's I
think that's what you see it not in all
the episodes but in some of the episodes
we know in short how to cultivate a
concern for future generations within
the framework of the old ethics we've
seen it done right believe in it we've
seen it yeah the restraints that it
cultivated are it must be said responses
to the limitations under which Jonah's
sorry Jonah's argued old ethics operated
that fact leads some to conclude that
the methods by which we were to
cultivate any concern for future
generations today would have to be
different indeed it is almost a
commonplace today to frame the
achievement of ethical behaviors in
terms of genetic or biochemical
engineering see for example the book
titled unfit for the future the need for
moral enhancement by Ingmar Pearson and
Julien Savile sq this is an Oxford
University Press book by the way
is not some you know non-mainstream way
of thinking but if such methods are not
themselves outright violation of yonus
--is imperative they are at least a
slippery slope very much in tension with
it so if we wanted to cultivate a
concern for future generations the
fashionable way of doing so the Pearson
and Savile askew way is not available to
us so we could operationalize Jonases
imperative in a different way couldn't
we try to use the same kinds of legal
and social tools that were used to
support the aristocratic ethos but now
we have to stop and think were we to do
so what would you be saying about the
actual novelty of our ethical
circumstances neither the means nor the
ends that define the ethos of concern
for future generations would actually be
new at all we just have to become Morris
to Craddock to reach this conclusion I
had to shift Jonah's very slightly off
his own ground but the point would
remain largely the same even with a more
precise representation of his starting
point
his imperative cannot enforce itself and
given the terms of his argument may not
be consistently enforced using the most
aggressive technological tools that call
forth its demand for restraint in the
first place right this isn't this is a
problem of technology that if he's right
technology cannot solve that would just
make the matter worse it appears as if
it could only be enforced
consistent with yonus own concerns by
the use of the traditional methods by
which any ethic is to be cultivated what
it amounts to then is suggesting that if
those methods are not grounded in the
most radical possibilities of
technological manipulation of the given
we would have to choose
to say so much the worse for those
radical possibilities but if we get this
far it seems to me we might start
wondering how much Jonas is imperative
adds to what we might achieve not just
by the means of an old ethic but by the
ends as well for example if a major
threat to the future of mankind is the
excessive material consumption that
threatens the viability of natural
ecosystems people are going to have to
consume less teaching the imperative
responsibility is not going to reduce
consumption any more than teaching
Aristotelian moderation would but would
not habituation to moderation serve as
an adjunct that could operationalize
Jonases imperative or again the
imperatives of responsibility surely
gives us one perspective from which to
understand what is wrong with the
aspirations of those who seek to
facilitate human extinction in the name
of technological progress but on the
other hand it is not exactly breaking
news that efforts to cheat death are
prideful hubristic and very likely to go
bad either way an old ethic of humility
would be an appropriate response but
then what would we lose if we started to
think about humility as a good in itself
just as we might come to understand in
the old way moderation is good now if we
become skeptical about the proposition
that our admittedly novel circumstances
require a correspondingly novel ethic we
might even be tempted by the argument
that jonas concedes too much to the
ethic of novelty or as we might say
disruption that is so prominent in our
technological aspirations the choices we
make that could lead to the most dire
outcomes right the quest for immortality
how did we get to the point where that's
what we're looking for if as Jonas does
we accept them as the necessary
consequence of novel circumstances
that's one thing we would just have to
say as Stuart brand said a long time ago
we are as gods and might as well get
good at it but that's not yours that
these are the choices we are faced with
might otherwise be taken as symptoms of
the disordered priorities which arise in
disordered souls we see this all the
time in small ways we bare our souls on
Facebook and then worry ourselves about
privacy we race to develop autonomous
cars even as we worry about the danger
of Technology out of control
we rail at the indignity of death but
then we demand Death with Dignity we say
we want a new technological ethic but of
course you'll have to let us do whatever
we want to do
hence it seems to me it's appropriate to
think in terms of that old ethic whereby
the reason by means of trained emotions
could control our desires yes it's
old-fashioned and yes that may sound
quaint to some of you and because it's
quaint
it may seem like it could not possibly
have any kind of impact in a real world
but if impractical impracticality is a
problem for my argument it is it seems
to me an even greater problem for those
who advocate some new ethic and here
again it's only our prejudice on behalf
of novelty that blinds us to the
impracticality of the new ethic for as
Jonas himself understands full well it
is far easier to call for a new ethic or
even develop one than to imagine one
that could be adopted today as the right
ethic since in our time
the intellectual domination of
relativism post-modernism and general
moral skepticism and laxness we find
ourselves in a situation where the
notion of any authoritative ethic has
become almost impossible to take
seriously in theory yet as far as
practical affairs go the more cap the
moral capital we are in fact expending
day by day is almost by definition
derived from some old ethic as it
remains more or less weakly embodied in
law customed norms and so on so for the
case that we simply had a choice between
trying to revive and invigorate what
already exists and starting over from
zero I think there's some practical
reason to favor the former and see the
latter as the impractical choice if our
goal is to protect the future of the
human race and the conditions for human
life on earth for future generations we
are going to have to find some ways to
exercise restraint with respect to at
least the widespread development of or
perhaps use of certain technological
possibilities while an imperative
responsibility could help clarify our
deliberations it will not enforce itself
unless we use some of the novel tools of
technology to control the use or
development of other tools of technology
an outcome seemingly at odds with
Jonas's own purposes restraint will
require self control and self control
the proper ordering of our souls we
really have no choice but to employ our
intellects and emotions to help keep the
animal organism under control up to this
point I think it is fair to say when
today we have even thought to ask
questions of what technologies to
develop or restrain the burden of proof
has quickly been assigned to restraint
and the default assumption has been that
to attempt to restrain is an unwarranted
assault on scientific or commercial or
medical freedom a risky Enterprise to
our eken
well-being or national security I think
it is worth considering the possibility
that the voice of freedom in such
debates is actually the voice of what
Louis calls our animal organism what
Socrates would have labeled the Hydra
that is the desiring part of our souls
there are good reasons why this should
be the case after all technology from
the start has played a crucial role in
the achievement of the comfortable
self-preservation that is the hallmark
goal of modern politics modern political
arrangements have increasingly made
their peace with understanding human
life as a perpetual and Restless desire
for power after power to quote Hobbes
ceasing only in death here again we
should never slight the good that has
come as a result but over the course of
time and has it become increasingly
clear that these results include the
liberation of the Hydra and as one might
say the deliberate pruning of its heads
in order to increase their number there
are these conditions make it very
difficult for us to distinguish between
liberty and license
we are very little inclined to ask
whether the freedoms we are protecting
are anything more than further
enslavement to the Hydra of our desires
you see this in the prospect I in the
promises that are made on behalf of
immersive virtual realities that we will
at last be able to fulfill all of our
wildest dreams and desires or again I
would adduce I'm not going to tell you
to search this out on the Internet but I
there was a wonderful interview in
connection with the Consumer Electronics
Show of a guy who's making sex dolls
right and one of the big features not
yet available but coming soon was that
these dolls would have under
interchangeable heads and personae good
right somebody sees it lest we think
this design
was in any way infected by
cisnormativity he made it clear that his
company eventually expected the complete
compatibility and interchangeability of
female and male heads bodies and
personae is it really some principled
commercial understanding of commercial
and intellectual freedom they would hold
us back from drawing some kind of line
at sex robots or is it one head of the
Hydra cherry of interfering with another
lest it be interfered with I don't know
whether your account these two examples
I've given is among those that threaten
the future and integrity of our humanity
as I think I would but the hydras desire
for power after power now emphatically
includes that the quest not end in death
the fact that we are nowhere close to
this seemingly perennial goal the fact
that it is not even clear that we are on
the verge of any extension of lifespan
as significant as the one that took
place during the 20th century does not I
think one would diminish the seriousness
of the undertaking to achieve freedom
from death it could be true to say it
seems to me both that the revolt against
death is a great sign of our humanity
and that men who are not mortal are no
longer men the desire to conquer death
could be a perennial powerful head of
the Hydra the best way to deal with it
the way that most expresses the genuine
freedom that comes from the ability of
reason and thumos or reason or intellect
and emotion to restrain desire is not
likely to be to give in to it none of us
I daresay look forward to death except
under God willing the rarest of
circumstances and I have some regret in
bringing my remarks to a close on this
topic but the quest overcome death
motivates our great tech barons no less
than it motivated the alchemists so in
many respects it is likely to be one of
the places where as Yana suggests we
would want to restrain technology if we
were willing to do so at all but here of
all places I think it is clear that the
new ethic of the imperative of
responsibility actually brings nothing
new
to the table even misses all of what the
old ethics offered for dealing with the
reality of death things like the
cultivation of resignation or of hope
short of dehumanizing biotechnological
interventions - faith death face death
faithfully or philosophically our like
difficult tasks tasks of a lifetime as
one might say that these all-too-human
tasks are not always perhaps not even
frequently actually completed is not
enough to justify justify wholesale
manipulations of our nature in a world
where some of our best and brightest or
at least richest are pursuing or
supporting projects whose goal would be
the elimination of humanity it is not
hard sorry it is hard not to have
intellectual sympathy with the onus
attempt to articulate an ethic that
favors the preservation of humanity into
the indefinite future it may seem that
the novelty of the goal would require us
to respond to it with corresponding
novelty as he have he has done but I've
tried to show tonight where I think it's
not so simple the old ethics was always
in a sense about the preservation of our
humanity delicately poised as it is
between the pull of beastliness and the
pull of godlike self-sufficiency the old
ethics knew that left to themselves most
people would lead the lives of cattle
and I have to say it often seems to me
that the promise of technology today is
to find ever more sophisticated ways to
keep us well pastured on the other hand
there is the more visionary promise that
we are on the verge of becoming homo
Deus as the title of a recent book put
it of transcending our humanity so to
the intelligence shorn of all limitation
of our poor biological bodies and minds
can increasingly transform the world in
its own image the answer of the old
ethics to both these anti human impulses
was the same a due regard for the proper
ordering of our souls with regard which
regard is
the hallmark of our humanity we would
gain thereby the restraint necessary to
be able to withstand the siren songs of
our subhuman and superhuman desires I
don't think we must believe that there
has yet been any fundamental change to
that situation as the same things
attract us the same powers will need to
be invoked to resist them the threat of
technology to our humanity can best be
met perhaps only be met by human beings
who know what it means to live like
human beings and are habituated to doing
so thank you very much
thank you dr. Reuben has agreed to sign
copies of his book eclipses of man human
extinction and the meaning of progress
immediately following the lecture we now
have time for a few questions please
raise your hand and wait for a
microphone to be brought to you hi so
this is kind of a particular question
but you talked about how our
person-to-person and I'm wondering like
for example this cell phone and like the
ability for us to be in contact with
each other
rapidly and across a much larger space
than we've seen before
how if we're ever trying to recover on
ancient ethics like you said how will
the development of the cell phone or
stuff like that aid in recovering that
does that does that make sense I think
so but you'll you'll tell by my answer
whether or not I understood cell phones
a very problematic invention from from
this point of view I mean yes it can
keep us in contact with each other over
over long distances and there are many
wonderful things that result from that
but there is also a kind of diminishment
of what it means to communicate one
human being with another that takes
place so you know all the myriad of
clues that we get when we speak
face-to-face with someone you know are
missing even when we're you know video
chatting they are they are imperfectly
represented it seems to me and so some
aspect of human communication gets
filtered out of the process you know I
mean I'm I'm old enough that I managed
you know I can remember time when when
to go on a date or something you
actually ask someone face-to-face I mean
[Applause]
so even if we in the West we're able to
become closer with that old ethics
master that moderation that sort of
social responsibility that we need how
how would we transmit that communicate
that to the non-western parts the world
in which it's it's needed most for
example in China and India or places
that have large carbon sinks like Africa
and South America how how can we get the
rest of the world onboard yeah so I've
heard questions like that many times now
I now yet I have yet to come up with
what I regard it as a remotely
satisfactory response I'll just say two
very quick things first of all you know
there's always something to be said for
getting your own house in order and and
and you know if if if if we were to get
our house in order and if it were to
have positive consequences then it may
be that other people would seeing that
would be interested in getting their
house in order in in like-minded ways
the other hand I gave you sorry but it's
it's one of the best works of science
fiction that I've ever read
extremely intelligently written it's
Neal Stephenson's the diamond age or a
young oh shoot sorry a young girls
Illustrated primer and Stevenson
imagines a world where way beyond the
nation-state
but you know like-minded groups of
people follow the ethics which define
them as peoples and end up in
competitive and sometimes dangerous
situation and there is a kind of
overarching but rather loose governance
of the
whole system it's just it's it's a book
worth it's a book worth reading you know
for the manner in which he takes you
know old ethics seriously and brings it
into a radically new world if we want to
presume preserve our future generations
would it be wise not to militarize our
new artificial intelligence yes but but
but let me answer that in qualified way
I mean because again these two questions
in my mind anyway are related we live in
a tough world we live in a competitive
world you know you there are things that
you you know national security is very
important and has to be taken seriously
in making these decisions already
fighter plane pilots rely on tremendous
amounts of computer assistance and
natural and artificial intelligence I
mean stealth planes I am told could not
be flown by a human being
operating alone as we do this I think
it's very important to keep human beings
right in the loop in authoritative
decision-making roles I do not believe
in the development of that the
development of autonomous artificial
intelligence military technology is a
good idea at all
thank you for your talk today to me to
be truly human and be too tethered to
humanity is two things is to one to
believe in a Supreme Being or God and
also to believe in our mortality and to
me to many of the Silicon Valley
Sultan's believe that they are God and
that they can manipulate things to live
forever and when you when you cease
mooring yourself to those two things of
believing in the supreme of believing in
God and believing in your mortality and
you think you can do anything else bad
things can happen and also thinking that
and these are just comments at mine I
like via comment technology to me is a
tool that we use it it should not be
something that is used on us that it
becomes that we become a tool of it
thank you no thank you I mean I I
alluded it's true only very delicately
to the to the role of faith in this but
I I certainly agree with you that it's
it's absolutely central and I mean at
one point in the in the book yonas
recognizes that you know even if old
ethics aren't good anymore there might
be something to be said if you could
sort of revive revive religion he just
doesn't think that that's really a
possible route to anything but you know
I think it is the tool thing yeah I mean
sure but I mean I think it also is true
that our tools change us right I think
that's just an unavoidable part of of
what it means to be users of technology
I mean apparently they do this in a very
literal way they you know you use a
hammer enough and the brain eventually
starts treating it as it treats your
hand right
so you know the knowing that's true
right
knowing that we kid ourselves if we say
oh it's just a tool you know I think is
an important step towards a full
appreciation of the impact these things
are having on us
thank you dr. Rubin my name is Spencer
I'm a sophomore here at Hillsdale you
mentioned just before you're a rebuttal
of the onus that ecological destruction
is not the chief concern it's more
willful destruction of humanity so my
question is do you see things like I was
mentioned militarizing or you know
technology advancing in a military
capacity and sort of destroying humans
physically being the chief concern or
something where humans lose their
humanity but perhaps are still alive so
much what's Tiesto's would calm in
without chests where do you see the
greater threat yeah I mean certainly the
the Luas problem remains a very serious
problem but I also think in some ways
we've gone beyond it I mean the you know
the the well Hans Moravec was mentioned
this afternoon I mean Hans Moravec was
one of the great early thinkers of the
transformation of human beings into
machines and and I really mean great
because there's a kind of honesty about
more of X presentation of it that is not
necessarily available across the board
but but you know you see in him this
it's absolutely he's looking at a world
without human beings he's looking in a
world where intelligence is now
instantiating in in in in mechanisms and
it's great it's you know it's like the
Borg are here and he loves them I mean
it's it's and and you know Ray Kurzweil
another major figure in this they
actively are seeking a replacement for
Humanity a Kurzweil puts his usual
delicacy he puts it this way you know
this is gonna happen he thinks this is
gonna happen and you know what he says
if you want to be mortal fine go be
mortal that's a problem that will solve
itself
hi I'm dr. Reuben my name is Hannah and
I just wanted a clarification on
something you said or the author that
you're speaking on said human nature and
condition are no longer fixed was that
something of the author or something you
believe so
so that's Jonah's Jonases description of
our present world we now have the
capacity to alter our nature as we see
fit
and I think descriptively he's right we
if even if we don't quite have that
capacity yet
it looks pretty clear like we are on the
very verge of gaining that capacity dr.
Reuben over here so you spoke about the
dangers of having research that extends
life past normal limits would you say
that not trying to play devil's advocate
but you know research that focuses on
curing terminal diseases like cancer
would you consider that unethical then
no no I mean the there's a difference
between in my mind anyway there's a
difference between the extension of
lifespan through curing diseases which
is what we saw in the 20th century
basically occurring or presenting
disease and the extension of lifespan
through altering our genetic makeup in
order to push us beyond the you know and
anything like a normal lifespan you know
we're not talking about people here who
would be you know in in in Yiddish you
say you know this hundreds on sake you
know you should live 120 years no we're
we're way beyond that conceptually
speaking you know 120 years fine
hello my name is Gabriel I'm a junior
here at NASA College so you had
mentioned earlier response to a question
over here that we need to like clean our
own house
first in how our older ethics relate to
other West non-western cultures but to
what extent even in the Western culture
if we have these older ethics that are
more objective on something farther back
to what point when do we stop and engage
these other changing more flexible
ethics is there a point where we have to
say no and put our foot down I know
you're not a politician so I'm not
asking for like legislation but you know
personal lives how are we supposed to
engage with our ethics to this modern
ethics
yeah I mean so I guess I guess I am then
this may be a weakness in the argument
but I but I guess I'm a great believer
in the power of example right of putting
your money when your mouth is you you
know you lead your life yourself with
like-minded people you you make your
choices along these lines and if you're
right
it'll people will see it people will see
the difference
you know I mean the the moral world is
for so many people these days so chaotic
that it seems to me hard to believe that
if they saw you know people like
themselves who were happy and you know
reasonably successful and able to you
know not live from one paycheck or one
day to the next you know you they might
start wondering well you know what what
she got that I haven't got right I mean
what's what's the difference here look
my the the order that runs my my
university is I am told the only
Catholic order that's allowed to operate
in North Africa in the Arab world and
why is that because they don't actively
proselytize right so is there really
nothing in it for them
no of course there's something in it for
them right the power of example is where
they've placed their bet it seems to me
we have time for one more question
thank you so much this isn't really so
much a question this afternoon I was
discussing that I hope with a student
that I hope this week would raise the
moral issues as much as the
technological issues I think there
inextricable and I said I think just
because we have the capacity to do
something doesn't mean we should and so
to connect with the old ethics we have
to ask ourselves should I do it and if I
should do it why should I do it and if I
shouldn't do it why should I not do it
and there it is it's simple but it's not
easy thank you very very much
[Applause]